and explain two things about these kinds
of questions because what are the duties
to draw two number lines just to graph
your solutions on the normal life and
then they provide you some information
about what kind of solutions they have
so I need to back up a little bit I need
to talk about and this is worth trying
out somewhere else in your book the
different kinds of families or the
classical way of saying it is the steps
of numbers that we talked about in our
folks and holidays difference in each
other okay because we are the language
that you're looking at in the question
directly follows from these different
family development so to begin with all
numbers start with counting everywhere
in the world every culture that has
divided numbers by way more order at all
start of accounting and we can never
called me the natural numbers now like I
said to you before mathematicians
famously lazy will write as little as
they possibly can so this end with a
kind of funky little double line to it
is the symbol for the natural numbers
you also unifor the counting numbers
because you count them okay so there one
two three four five six etc off to
Achilles some people count 0 as an acid
natural number some people vote I'll
just put that to one side after the
natural numbers 1 2 3 4 5 we then in g7
we extended that not just from one point
to positive pity but also in the other
direction to negative intermission right
so he says actually you can have numbers
which have direction and we call that
integer ok now the symbol for integers
force training which is not I it
actually is dead again with the double
applied which is a reference to all of
the German mathematician two
contributors enormous mountain incident
incident in the eighteen and 1900s ok I
think it's Germans bizarre which has
recapping them I'll say the counting
ladies designer they extend from
negative infinity and in their 50 and
they keep on going just like the
National now I've to get the naturals
and integers you get the rationals now
again doesn't plan to deal with now
there's a great story behind why they're
called rational and why we think of the
word rational I'd like it makes sense
but it really is about the word ratio
right which explains why these are
actually talking about fractions aha a
third 357 on 891 all of these are
fractured is civil unions q do you
reckon you could get it is a word in
English language that that you stand for
that has to do with fractions anyone
think yeah question very good keep your
question okay so these are all the
fractions and so on I'm looking right on
will refuse to me now after that you can
divide this in a few different ways but
for your purposes what you see is the
real moment okay and that system what
I've written up here again if it our
thanks for the circumstance or what it
says we're a double line in there you
find all different kinds of numbers in
fact pretty much every number you ever
have to deal with is a real number
square roots of we achieve like thirds
right I transcendental numbers like time
and E which you can't write even as a
sir all of them are in the real numbers
now there is no basis are we call them
complex numbers and that's a story for
another day now the most important part
of this diagram for you are the integers
and the real because they're the ones
that appears frequently in the special
reason it's your city park so these idea
that these done here
let's at least one at a time if you
can't give it a question you simplify
all of the algebra out and this is your
final one they want you to grab all of
the numbers X ratifies where X is a real
number remember is you use a real
numbers include all kinds of weird
working on this straight like third like
fraction like pie at all okay so if you
put them on another line the first thing
I want to point out is every number line
should have the most important number on
the entire thing which is you look
you've got a happier there where is
fires going to be even have to put every
single marketing services to the right
of 0 during the right box now to the
right to the right you're going to start
from firing indicate that boundaries we
can sort of feedback for the circle of
it they should be colored into five
parts of your region and then you can do
well everything else on the rain in
sight they're all included you go as far
as you like all those others satisfy
that inequality okay a couple of minor
notes please see where my body is is on
the number line it's not hovering look
at where my arrow is it's on the number
like hovering no reason why is because
you've been drawing number one is a what
whenever you give a Cartesian plane
right you got an x-axis and then you go
to wire although the action on that
plane up and down it has meaning it
indicates there's a vertical values or
something else but there isn't anything
like that here that's why we're positive
number how look at this one x is less
than five original fandom line with the
same point of reference of this time
what family of Knossos am i dealing with
look carefully these are the integers
right to their whole numbers you have
some other negative but they're all hold
right so I want to all of the whole
numbers I actually I'm going to add one
more thing gr
sometimes you get asked for positive
whole numbers positive images sometimes
you get off some negative one so where
are all of the positive interview that I
less than five can you name them one two
three four that's it right now thing is
you can't do the numbers in between
right like for instance if I've got one
two three four one and us one half is
not one of the images so you can't just
call it all the way through what you
must do is labeled just like you labeled
this endpoint here this is one two three
and four that you color each of those
individually on the number line itself
okay can't have any those gaps you
couldn't look out I big guys last time
disappoint run frequently you'll end up
with something and you're between
boundaries trance so again you put the
movement quite a number on the whole
number line this time is one of two
numbers it's important that your scale
is at least somewhat conflicted if that
supposed to be a distance of one then
one two three four five that ought to be
a single scale okay I'm between this is
a filled circle but look at that
boundary is negative one included it's
marketed know if you find that Thunder
for a hollow circle there and then I'm
going to join up everything ok